check this out we have the brand new
dual sense Edge wireless controller this
is a new controller for Sony PlayStation
I'm so hyped about this because I love
using a customizable controller that has
back paddle buttons yes spoiler we
haven't got to that yet but I love this
case and here's the controller itself
and you can see that it looks very
familiar like the previous PlayStation
controller but it has these added
bonuses there's two options for the back
paddles there's these ones and then
there's two Half Dome back buttons which
I'm actually a really big fan of there's
six different keycaps there's the two
standard two high Dome and two low Dome
so depending upon your play style you
can choose what you like this is a cable
connector that will lock your cable into
place into the controller so it doesn't
disconnect while gaming I also really
like this carrying case it comes with a
USB braided cable which is very fancy
and this little back slot opens up so
you can charge it while it's in the case
these little switches let you adjust the
tension on the triggers and here's the
controller overall it's pretty cool